tras el tercer atentado terrorista del
martes la violencia aquí en israel y
cisjordania ocupada no ha hecho más que
avivar se la prueba de este jueves al
menos tres jóvenes muertos en dos hechos
diferentes en una de las redadas y
detenciones que está llevando a cabo el
ejército israelí en el norte de
cisjordania las fuerzas israelíes
mataron a dos palestinos durante un
intercambio de disparos en el campo de
refugiados de yenín mientras que en un
autobús cerca del asentamiento de 9
daniel un palestino que apuñaló con un
destornillador a un israelí murió por
disparos de otro pasajero en este
contexto y luego de que se registraran
11 fallecidos en tres ataques en una
semana el gobierno de israel ha adoptado
a su vez una estrategia de mano dura
principalmente contra las comunidades
árabes no sólo ha elevado la presencia
de varias fuerzas de seguridad sino que
se ha multiplicado los arrestos los
controles en checkpoint y se ha
dispuesto el retiro de permisos de
trabajo y la demolición de viviendas de
personas allegadas a dichos atacantes
el primer ministro israelí naftalí
bennett instó incluso a los ciudadanos
israelíes a estar vigilantes y portar
armas siempre que cuenten con una
licencia para medidas entre las que por
ahora no hay una restricción al festejo
del ramadán que inicia este fin de
semana y elevaría sin duda las tensiones
quienes se alimentan de este clima son
las posiciones más extremistas por un
lado el brazo armado de la yihad
islámica que ha elevado el estado de
alerta y por otro lado el parlamentario
de ultraderecha itamar ben-gvir que
recorrió la explanada de las mezquitas a
un monte del templo e instó a no
rendirse frente a los terroristas un
paseo fuertemente custodiado y libre de
incidentes pero que se ha tildado de una
provocación